[Musique]
sensation sensation le mag
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur sensation
d'association avec TV 78 je suis
aujourd'hui avec Laurent Merker
vice-président de 50 ans en Yvelines
délégué à l'urbanisme et à l'aménagement
du territoire et maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux bonjour bonjour
Alors l'interview va se passer en deux
temps va d'abord parler de votre
fonction à 50 ans en Yvelines mais aussi
de votre commune alors je vous propose
de démarrer avec votre délégation vous
êtes délégué à l'urbanisme et à
l'aménagement du territoire quels sont
vos objectifs justement les objectifs de
votre délégation
l'aménagement du territoire c'est c'est
le temps long moyen court moyen terme et
long terme que l'on peut avoir sur une
une aire donnée et c'est vrai que c'est
dans l'ADN de 50 ans en Yvelines
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines étant parti de
de terre agricoles et de petits villages
pour réaliser une très grande ville de
plus de 220 000 habitants ça veut dire
que depuis 40 ans nous sommes dans
l'aménagement et que donc quand vous
pensez à aménagement vous pensez à la
fois comme je le disais à moyen terme
les choses qui permettent de répondre
aux besoins
immédiats des entreprises des habitants
de tous les occupants mais en même temps
qu'il faut préparer l'avenir et regarder
comment proposer un territoire équilibré
qui répondent aux besoins à la fois des
gens qui vivent sur le territoire mais
en même temps de proposer une dynamique
et une attractivité qui permette aussi
d'accueillir encore de main des
entreprises de faire venir des salariés
de faire venir des gens qui ont envie de
vivre sur 50 ans en Yvelines donc ça
c'est tout le travail qui est fait en
lien évidemment avec d'autres secteurs
comme le développement économique comme
les mobilités et puis bien sûr toutes
les compétences qui peut y avoir au
niveau de 50 ans justement pour proposer
un territoire et équilibré attractif aux
habitants mais c'est à votre délégation
doit et se veut être au plus proche des
autres délégations pour travailler
finalement main dans la main mais ça
c'est de toute façon le l'ADN aussi de
50 ans de vie c'est de travailler
maintenant la main avec les autres
délégations bien sûr il faut travailler
de manière collective c'est très
important et
c'est travailler à la fois avec les
autres services mais évidemment avec le
département avec la région avec les
services de l'État quand on travaille
sur le carrefour de la malmedonne par
exemple sur la nationale 10 évidemment
nous sommes plusieurs partenaires autour
de la table lorsque l'on travaille sur
l'accueil de grandes épreuves sur le
territoire c'est la même chose lorsqu'un
quartier va se réaliser comme le
quartier des saveurs à Guyancourt on
travaille avec un établissement public
d'aménagement avec la Région le
Département l'Etat donc à chaque fois
voilà on est toujours dans ces
dynamiques multipartenariale pour
pouvoir proposer le meilleur projet à la
fin et votre fonction est donc notamment
de veiller à développer à fournir un
cadre de vie agréable aux 50 chinois
mais également de veiller à une
répartition équilibrée des ressources
entre les différentes communes du
territoire alors qu'est-ce que ça
signifie concrètement et surtout comment
cela va se traduire sur le terrain et
bien c'est une question d'équilibre
c'est-à-dire que si vous entendez
aujourd'hui les aménageurs au niveau de
l'État ou définir ce qu'est le
territoire idéal c'est un territoire
dans lequel on a beaucoup d'ESP dans
lequel on a des aménités dans lequel on
a du logement de l'activité de la
formation il se trouve qu'à 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est comme ça que le
territoire a été pensé donc nous avons
ce gros avantage d'être déjà aujourd'hui
un territoire qui présente un certain
équilibre même si évidemment il peut y
avoir des disparités entre certaines
communes derrière l'important pour nous
justement c'est de regarder quelles
peuvent être les à certains dans
certains endroits de l'agglomération des
points nécessaires pour faire évoluer je
pense au plateau de Trappes au plateau
urban trap par exemple qui va atténuer
cette coupure qui existe au milieu de ce
territoire là dans le même temps ça va
être comme je l'évoquais avec le
quartier des savoirs la création d'un
nouveau quartier d'une gare qui va
évidemment apporter quelque chose
d'important pour Guyancourt mais qui va
être aussi par cette nouvelle liaison
ferroviaire qui va arriver sur le
territoire de Saint-Quentin un point
d'attractivité pour l'ensemble des 50
chinois et pas seulement l'aiguille en
courtois alors vous avez déjà justement
évoqué un projet un finalement que que
vous mettez en place avec avec 50 ans en
Yvelines est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
projet dans les années à venir justement
que vous voulez mettre en place pour
justement avoir un cadre de vie un peu
un peu meilleur on va dire pour les 50
chinois alors en fait il y a aujourd'hui
des projets sur toutes les communes de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines c'est aussi ça
la grande force d'un territoire comme le
nôtre c'est que une intercommunalité
comme celle de Saint-Quentin à Yvelines
joue un réel effet de levier qui permet
de débloquer et de lancer des politiques
extrêmement ambitieuses sur les
territoires que ce soit avec des
aménagements extrêmement structurants
mais aussi évidemment dans la prise en
compte des centres bourgs des parties un
peu anciennes que l'on peut avoir sur le
territoire donc ce sont toutes ces
aspects qu'il faut que l'on regarde que
l'on regarde collectivement il y a un
exécutif qui est partagé avec tous les
maires de 50 ans en Yvelines et ça je
pense que c'est une grande force aussi
pour nous et qui nous permet de prendre
en considération ce qui peut sembler
être quelque chose de d'extrêmement
limité d'un point ponctuel sur un
territoire comme de projet extrêmement
structurant à l'échelle de tout 50 ans
en Yvelines je pense à l'accueil des JO
mais bien d'autres sujets encore de ce
type et vous avez évoqué justement les
Jeux olympiques et paralympiques 2024 en
quoi votre délégation aura un rôle à
jouer justement dans ces gros événement
pardon alors
je ne suis pas nécessaire la délégation
aménagement urbanisme n'est pas
nécessairement aujourd'hui
la délégation qui va jouer un rôle en
fait elle a déjà joué ce rôle puisque en
permettant la création du quartier du
vélo drone sur Montigny-le-Bretonneux
précisément nous avons pu mettre en
place les moyens nécessaires à l'accueil
des GOP ce qui se passe en ce moment sur
la colline de longcourt c'est la même
chose mais disons que là nous arrivons
dans les derniers mois avant les Jeux
Olympiques donc maintenant ça sera à
d'autres services mobilité
au service événementiel à d'autres
services de l'agglomération de continuer
le rôle là encore une fois dans un
partenariat que l'on maintient entre
tous les services on en revient à ce que
vous disiez tout à l'heure vous c'est à
moyen et long terme finalement et le
court terme c'est après les autres
délégations qui continuent finalement le
travail que vous avez commencé à mettre
en place le vélo de route il faut se le
rappeler dans le cadre de Paris 2012
c'est ça remonte alors le remerka vous
êtes également maire de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux alors pouvez-vous
nous dire selon vous en quoi
Montigny-le-Bretonneux participe à la
force de 50 ans en Yvelines alors
d'abord par sa situation géographique
Montigny ayant la plus grosse gare de 50
ans en Yvelines avec 70 000 passages
jours avec les sorties de de l'autoroute
qui sont là est un centre une polarité
importante de Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
l'autre point qui est important je
l'évoquais tout à l'heure c'est qu'à cet
endroit-là particulièrement on rencontre
une mixité fonctionnelle extrêmement
élevée entre l'université le centre
commercial régional tout le tissu
économique avec les zones d'activités
qui sont autour et qui se partagent
entre Montigny aiguillon court autour de
ce que l'on appelle l'hypercentre et
donc on a là une réelle concentration de
extrêmement
déterminante et pour autant au beau
milieu de cet espace là nous avons aussi
le départ du parc des sources de la bief
c'est-à-dire la pleine nature en plein
centre-ville donc un centre-ville
extrêmement riche mais en même temps
extrêmement atypique parce que
qui propose aussi cette ce cadre de vie
ce cadre vert extrêmement important et
puis c'est aussi un lieu vous le vous le
savez qui avec l'hyper centre va
connaître une mutation extrêmement
importante dans les prochains mois ça
nous y travaillons depuis 2019 à présent
avec une grande concertation qui avait
eu lieu et donc on va complètement
transformer ces espaces qui avaient été
pensés de manière extrêmement minérale à
l'époque très orienté vers la voiture
pour proposer demain des espaces de vie
des espaces conviviaux avec des grandes
terrasses de restaurants avec des
espaces pour les mobilités douces
extrêmement importantes évidemment quand
on crée ça à cet endroit particulier qui
est une polarité importante de 50 ans en
Yvelines c'est d'abord pour les
habitants bien sûr mais aussi pour tous
les salariés des entreprises qui
travaillent autour et qui trouveront là
un lieu très attractif et derrière là
encore quand je vous dis on pense long
terme créer cela c'est à la fois
répondre à des besoins du territoire
mais c'est aussi pour demain maintenir
50 ans en Yvelines dans la course qu'il
peut y avoir à l'échelle de toute l'Île
de France pour attirer les entreprises
puisqu'on sait qu'aujourd'hui accueillir
des entreprises c'est la solution pour
un une collectivité de pouvoir assurer
la pérennité de ses ressources alors
vous l'avez évoqué il y a la mobilité à
Montigny Montigny-le-Bretonneux
notamment avec la gare et les mobilités
douces vous avez construit ou en tout
cas rénover énormément de pistes
cyclables il y a aussi les trottinettes
électriques qui ont pris place sur sur
tout le territoire de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines quels sont vos
projets justement pour pour 2023 est-ce
qu'il y a des priorités pour 2023 alors
il se trouve qu'il y a actuellement la
conjonction entre le plan vélo de la
région qui s'appelle vélo Île-de-France
à présent le plan vélo portait par le
Département le plan vélo de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui va
consacrer un budget extrêmement
important sur sur cette thématique et
que nous avons nous aussi consacré sur
ce mandat un plan vélo avec un budget de
500.000 euros de façon à pouvoir
travailler à la fois alors là je
reprends à l'échelle des différents
plans que je viens d'évoquer des voies
structurantes
importantes et je pense là-dessus à la
passerelle qui va bien tôt être
construite qui va nous permettre de
rejoindre à pied en bicyclette l'île de
loisirs
donc on va à la fois être sur des des
choses comme ça à la fois quand je
parlais de l'hyper centre réalisé des
sections de de mobilité douce qui a ce
jour n'existe pas et qui sont sur le
territoire vraiment très important
puisque ce sont celles qui irriguent la
gare et tout le centre tout le quartier
et en même temps dans les quartiers nous
de
rénover les parties cyclables qui sont
un peu fatigués et en même temps de
conforter tout ce qui est stationnement
sur tous les sites qui requiert de
pouvoir poser son vélo quand on va aller
faire ses courses aller à une école etc
etc donc on travaille sur tous ces
aspects en même temps et en même temps
on travaille sur le savoir rouler pour
permettre à des personnes de se mettre à
à la bicyclette au vélo et on le
travaille aussi bien avec les enfants
qu'avec les adultes on aura l'occasion
de toute façon de revenir sur sur ce
projet surtout les autres projets parce
que Montigny-le-Bretonneux se développe
énormément merci beaucoup Laura Mercat
d'avoir été avec nous sur sensation pour
plus d'informations peut se rendre sur
le site Montigny 78.fr et pour revoir ou
réécouter cette émission rendez-vous sur
notre site et notre application radio
sensation
[Musique]